Before getting into a negotiation,
it's very important to set a floor and a
ceiling so you know where to move,
right?
Because if you don't,
you can be manipulated and you can,
you know,
loose yourself in the emotions.
Because if you're a good negotiator,
you will obviously try at least to be
completely disconnected emotionally from
the deal and negotiation itself.
Although you will play emotional.
So if you are not upset,
you can play upsets.
Um,
but none of that matters unless you
don't,
unless you don't have a floor and a
ceiling.
So you need to know if you go under the
floor,
you need to walk out or you know,
and the negotiation and at the ceiling
you need to know to accept so you can
close the deal.
Time is very interesting when it comes
to negotiation.
I always say in real estate at time
kills everything,
all deals.
But this a little bit of time,
a few seconds,
minutes,
or sometimes a couple of hours depending
on the situation,
which you can use and delay to get where
you want because people get frustrated
to a certain point and in a good way.
If you don't give the information right
away,
just hold it back tiny,
tiny bits and make them wait.
That could be good.
As an example,
when I go into an apartment and the
seller is,
they're always asking me at the end of
the appointment,
so Frederick,
what is my penthouse worth?
I never ever give a price in the
apartments.
One because I want to do my research and
really go home and think about it.
And I don't want to be drawn into any
excitement,
which I could potentially be cause it's
so beautiful.
But it's also the purpose of this
discussion.
Having them wait three and a half hours
for an email to come with a price will
make them want it more.
And then having it come in writing,
we'll feel more substantial and real
because it's coming in an email.
He had to wait for it.
Okay.